[Music]
[Applause]
Dean blandino Fox NFL rules analyst
former NFL VP of officiating he was in
studio when the Cowboys Lions
controversy took place at the end of the
game with that two-point conversion Dean
joins us now what did you see in the
moment with that play
Dean so in the moment what I saw was it
was unusual to say the least because
typically when a lineman reports it's
just that lineman they swipe the front
of their Jersey they go to the referee
but actually there were there were two
lineman pan and and Taylor Decker that
went to referee brand Allen and then a
third lineman that was running onto the
field Dan Skipper um toward Allen and
then and then obviously Brad announces
70 is reporting is eligible and and that
that you know that whole the whole play
really predicates on 68 being being
eligible because he's going to play the
end of the line and he's the one that's
going to go out and catch the pass so it
was unusual to see two and a third
offensive lineman kind of going toward
the referee to almost make it look like
they were you know one or or two or all
three were reporting but obviously there
was there was some kind of
miscommunication that took place because
the Lions certainly wanted 68 to be the
eligible player did the Lions do
anything wrong no I the Lions did not do
anything wrong they they
and I have no doubt in my mind obviously
not knowing what was said but I have no
doubt in my mind that 68 said that he
was reporting to the referee you don't
you can't run that play without 68 and
that's practice this is something this
is a two-point try with so much riding
that game playoff implications so
there's no doubt in my mind that 68 is
reporting I do think the way they
presented it um created a little bit of
confusion for Brad Allen I think he went
too fast I think there's some
accountability on on the official side
as well 70 had reported earlier during
the game he sees 70 coming in he assumes
it's 70 and uh and goes too fast so I
think there's there's I don't think the
lines did anything wrong by rule I just
think the environment created a
situation where where quite frankly
Brett Allen assumed something that
wasn't true okay but they gather up
after that can you you know I mean why
can't you just correct that or why
doesn't can the home office helped them
correct that the lions were saying Jared
gof was saying Dan Campbell was saying
hey he reported he was the tackle
eligible here why couldn't they just say
you know what we made a mistake you know
at that point I don't think they thought
they made a mistake I think Brad Allen
thought that 70 was reporting so and
they still in the pool report they had
70 reporting so I don't think the the
league or the officiating crew thought
that they made a mistake um you know
they he did make the announcement I
don't think it came over the broadcast
but I have seen some videos on social
media where the announcement was made in
the stadium a lot of times those
announcements are hard to hear when
you're at field level and and I just
think that that miscommunication
combination of going too fast what what
the lies presented and again I think you
can't there's certainly accountability
I'm not I'm not absolving the
officiating crew in this situation I
think Brad just went into kind of autod
drive mode and assumed 70 was reported
then help me understand when the coaches
get together with the officials prior to
the start of the game what is discussed
and do you think that that was discussed
by Dan Campbell to the officials yeah
I'm sure it was discussed so 90 minutes
before the game two officials go to the
home coach two officials go to the away
Coach they visit in the locker room they
go through any questions the coach may
have um any special plays any Gadget
plays and and from my understanding Dan
did explain to the officials that 70
would report during the game um we do
have a a tackle eligible play that we
may run I don't know to what detail or
what extent it was explained to the crew
pregame but that's normal protocol that
happens every game when you have
something because you don't want the
officials to be caught off guard in a
situation like that and maybe throw a
flag where it it it isn't a foul and I
think that's why those those meetings
happened and I know that a conversation
took place between the officials and
Coach Campbell before the game it just
looked it felt like the officials were
blaming the
lions like they they created they were
trying to be too cute you know that it
just felt that way in the postgame
interview it it it did and and I've
explained it that way too look I think
the lions were trying to disguise who
was eligible but there's nothing illegal
about that there there's no there's no
um you know foul there and I do again I
can't imagine them having this play in
in this situation and 68 is not going to
tell the referee I'm eligible and again
I I do think it's just the official went
too fast um and you know here we are
talking about it talking to Dean
blandino Fox NFL rules analyst looking
back on this season what stands out good
and bad with the
referees well I think there's been some
high-profile misses I think you look at
this crew the Brad Allen crew they've
had a tough year quite frankly you go
back to the Packers Chiefs game they've
had some situations
I do think the the league is is using
technology more and I think that's a
good thing keep the game moving correct
obvious mistakes but the scrutiny just
continues to increase and I think we're
I honestly think we're at a Tipping
Point I think we're at a Tipping Point
with officiating and where do we want to
go from here do we do we need to
implement more replay and more
technology um you know my personal
feelings is we got to get back to the
basics the core what is you know we're
missing pass interference we're not
missing it because of Technology we're
missing it either we're out of position
we're not getting good direction we're
not being consistent so I do think we're
at a Tipping Point and uh and I think
the the you know ownership and and as we
get into the competition committee
process in the offseason I think
officiating is going to be a big topic
on the agenda okay but what would be
your advice or recommendations of now
what should the NFL do you said we're at
a Tipping Point okay I'm going to make
you the
commissioner what do you do so for me I
think we've got take a good look at the
officiating Department structure we need
to for for very long it's been
officiating is and for lack of a better
term and necessary evil right it's the
officials are important they're critical
to the outcome of the game but but
whenever we're talking about it it's
usually negative but it's such an
integral part of of of what happens on
the field on on game day so I think you
got to look at the department look at
the structure do we have the right
people in place are we giving good
direction the competition committee
process that process say is there is
there conversation during the season are
the competition committee members and
it's hard because you've got head
coaches Mike Tom and Mike Vel they're
trying to win football games they're
they don't have time to jump on
conference calls and do these other
things but can we create a structure
where you can have conference calls
throughout the season maybe it's once a
month whatever it is to kind of see
where we are with officiating what are
the issues how can we correct it before
the season ends and not just because
once the season ends if we get through
the playoffs without any controversy
everybody will kind of tend to forget
we'll get into February and March and uh
and nothing will get done I do think the
league needs to take a good hard look at
officiating the structure and how we're
training these officials yeah and and
you bring up a great Point imagine that
this happened in the
postseason that's when we have change
when it you know it's really impactful
um and imagine if it happened against
the Cowboys like it went against the
Cowboys and Jerry Jones all of a sudden
went on a crusade things would change no
doubt I mean we saw the 2018 NFC
Championship game with the missed call
and the P deference we changed the rule
and it didn't it didn't work it lasted
one year so the playoffs are going to be
I really and it's unfortunate but I
think the playoffs are the that's the
the key point if the playoffs go well
and there's no controversy people will
forget about the regular season and
they'll say everything's great if we
have a bunch of these types of plays in
the playoffs then I think it it it's all
heightened and then the right and
especially if it happens certain teams
more high-profile um I think then that
that that drives change when the
official goes under the hood how many
voices does he hear how how many people
are talking to the official it it it is
personally there's too many voices right
now you have a replay official you have
several people in New York at the at the
league office and there's probably four
or five people talking to each other and
and I think that's too many people um I
think it's become more of a committee
decision um you know when I was there it
was it was myself and the referee
communicating through the play and we
were trying to just get to a consensus
anytime you add more people to the mix
it's going to get harder to get to a
consensus it's going to take longer
you're going to be less efficient so
there there's probably four or five
people right now that are communicating
during those reviews and I I think
they're taking too long great to talk to
you again thanks for joining us we
appreciate it as like you know one of
these days well well there'd be no
reason to have you on if everything's
good
Dean no no only only when things go go
bad so thanks for joining us as always
thanks for having me Dean blandino Fox
NFL rules analyst you know when fritzy
reaches out it's like uh you know hey
Dean Dan wants talked to you oh great